so there's a big paragraph right
um I'm going to just say this is this is
not a conditional probability but it's
just probability for starters but the
conditional Parts the hard part so we've
got these three Sports rugby soccer
cross country right rugby soccer cross
country now the tricky thing is when you
start to read it right
60 students they try out for each of the
three sports but some of them try out
for multiple Sports and it's like they
overlap the groups overlap now that's
the indication to you if you have a look
at the numbers right 32 for rugby 29 for
soccer 15 for cross country even just
looking at those three numbers you can
see they add up to more than 60 right so
you're like okay clearly I'm double
counting some of these and so what we
want to do is work out which groups have
been counted more than once and then we
can answer all the questions that have
come for us okay so because there are
three things what I'm gonna ask you to
do is you open there right start by
drawing up we're going to have like a
big box here
and this will indicate all of our
students right everyone in the sample
space as it were
now because there are three different
options I'm going to draw like a circle
for each of the three things right so
I'll have a rugby Circle and then I'll
have a soccer one and then I'll have a
cross-country one
and you can see and I would label them
accordingly as well I've got other
colors here so if I call this
um actually you know I'll stay with
black just for now this circle here the
top left one is rugby this one is soccer
and this one is cross country so for
instance
if you have a look back at the question
right it tells you 32 trade out for
rugby so in this whole circle there will
be 32 people right but like are they 32
here or here or here or here I don't
actually know how it's broken up that's
the tricky part right and so we can't
start with the 32 and the 29 and the 15
because if we just put them on there
we've got more than 60 you're like so
what other information can I start with
so go all the way to kind of the end of
the question they give you lots of
numbers right
the last piece of information that they
give you before they ask you to draw a
diagram
the last piece of information is kind of
the most
um
it's the most specific like it tells you
about these five students and they did
all three right so we're on the diagram
would those five students go if they did
all three of the sports right so
um this is helpful if you have another
color you can but if you don't know
about it I'm going to put five students
right there okay
now what this means is I can kind of
work backwards through the question
which is like a key problem solving
strategy when you're like I don't know
where to begin often starting at the end
is helpful so now when you have a if I
literally go backwards right I know that
five prayer for all three Sports then it
says eight
try it out for rugby and cross country
so on my diagram here's rugby here's
cross country so this is the overlap so
there's eight students in this group but
I've already counted five of them do you
see that so then in this little other
spot how many should I have
it's three right I might use red for
this one so there the three and the five
there's my eight right so it's like okay
eight trade out for rugby and cross
country tick
again going backwards
nine tried out for soccer and cross
country so what number should I put here
four
can you tell me what to do next
so that's this region here so if there's
11 in total then that leaves six very
good so that's six and five gives you
the eleven okay and now we can go back
one more layer so remember we started
off saying there's 32 students who did
rugby so in this area
is the only remaining area where the
rest of the 32 are so if I do 32 and
then I take away the ones that I've
already counted
um 11 plus 3 is 14.
so then how many students do I have here
hold on yeah yeah they're very good I'm
asking you to carry the one in your head
okay that's fine there we go so can you
see now if I go 18 6 5 and 3 put them
all together there's the 32 they told us
about at the start of the question right
but now I know how it's broken down
let's have a look at the other ones
soccer
29 so this should be 29 take away how
many do I already have
very good
so that gives me how many just in soccer
right and then the last one 15 tried for
cross country
so in total I got 15 but I've already
counted that looks like 12.
so there's only three who just did cross
country okay now if you have a look the
five the three four five six which is
just the coincidence
18 14 3 okay is this all the students
now
one of the ways I can tell is if you
have a look at the question just have a
look at the parts a b c and d see how
Part D it says like was there anyone who
didn't try out for a sport so they're
already like posing the question is
there anyone that should be on the
outside of these three circles right so
let's have a look here
right at the start we said
um the rugby players was 32 right
32 so I don't need to add up all these
again I already know there's 32 in this
circle
so if I say
um all of the students is 60
but then what I want to take away just
like I took away in these screws right
I'll take away the 32 rugby players
that's everyone in this circle over here
there's 18.
and then the last group I have
encountered is this three like that
right so when I'm adding that up that
looks like 53 to me so 60 take away 53
is seven
right so that's how I know by looking at
the rest of these numbers are there are
seven students not accounted for so they
didn't trap for anything does that make
sense
in some ways from here like that's all
the hard work I actually think the rest
of it is not that difficult but just
just for the sake of it let's see if we
know what we're doing right
part A says
probability of a random student trying
out for one sport
so
can you help me work out on the diagram
which of the students maybe you can
refer to my colors or things like that
which students can you see only trade
out for one sport
uh
yeah it's these ones that are circled
isn't it right so 18 14 3 that's my
um
uh what's the word I'm working for
favorable outcomes they're the ones I'm
interested in and exactly as you said
I'm selecting from all the students at
random right so that's why you divide by
60 I don't really know what that is but
your calculator can do that right
um
let's keep going I don't think we need
to write this try it out for exactly two
sports what's exactly two sports mean
yeah very good so it's two sports but
not three because it says exactly two
right so you'd add up three four and six
divided by 60. when it gets to part C it
says trailer four at least two sports so
it includes those ones we just counted
but it would also include if you went
for three sports that's still included
in at least two does that make sense
yeah so you have to be quite careful
with the wording
um these questions often a single word
will change the kind of fraction that
you create so you get a completely
different answer
how does that feel okay with that